hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the gut microbiome in
myalgic encephalomyelitis chronic
fatigue syndrome in neuroimmune disease
presented by maureen hanson we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented and sponsored by
labrys the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars at dancing
scientific collaboration and learning I
am Christina jewel of lab woods and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
will be pushing out a few polls these
goals posts are anonymous and we
encourage you to respond before we begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing this
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continued
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CTE
button are located at the bottom left
hand corner of your webpage and follow
the process of obtaining your credits
now I'd like to introduce marine hansen
marine our Hansen is Liberty High Baily
professor in the department of molecular
biology and mathematics at Cornell
University in Ithaca New York
she received a BS degree at Duke
University and a PhD in so
and developmental biology from Harvard
University after completing an NIH and
RSA postdoctoral fellowship at Harvard
she joined the faculty of the biology
department at University of Virginia
before moving to Cornell she presently
has a diverse research program involving
gene expression and intracellular
organelles in plants and humans she has
a special interest in the
pathophysiology of myalgic
encephalomyelitis and chronic fatigue
syndrome I will now turn this
presentation over to Maureen
if Sears we may be having some technical
difficulties connecting with MS Hanson
do you mind holding just one moment
while we figure out these technicalities
we're having a webcam issue just one
moment
be switching right over to her thanks
for your patient
hello can you hear me now okay I'm going
to now begin my talk about the gut
microbiome in myalgic encephalomyelitis
also known as chronic fatigue syndrome
which is a neuroimmune disease more
information is available from my lab
website which is which is shown on this
first slide I'm going to give you an
outline of my talk I'm going to have a
first part of my talk is first part of
my talk is going to be a description of
the disease that's known as mecfs I'm
going to start with the definition that
was utilized in 1994 and a more recent
definition in 2015 the diag new
diagnostic criteria I'm also going to
describe a little bit about post
exertional malaise which is the hallmark
symptom of this disease and also give
you a brief summary of immunological
findings as this is also a immunology
conference then i'm going to go into our
study of the gut microbiome and the any
CFS so I want to start first with
describing what this disease is without
knowing something about the disease it's
really not easy to interpret the
information about the microbiome that
we'll be presenting later myalgic means
pain or tenderness and one or more
muscles and encephalomyelitis means of
inflammation of the brain and spinal
cord typically due to acute viral
infection one problem with this name
that concerns medical professionals is
that in most cases we don't
have good evidence that there is
actually inflammation of the brain and
spinal cord in most of the patients who
present with the disease
therefore in 1988 the Center for Disease
Control decided to decided to change
this name other disease to chronic
fatigue syndrome published in the paper
that I show here now one problem about
this name chronic fatigue syndrome is it
really results in people not
understanding the seriousness of the
disease okay so the 1994 CDC definition
for chronic fatigue syndrome required
unexplained persistent or relapsing
fatigue that said new or definite onset
and a substantial reduction in previous
level of activities but in addition
there had to be at least four of these
symptoms lasting at least six months
difficulties with memory problems of
sleep muscle pain headaches tender lymph
node nodes increased malaise following
exertion sore throat and joint pain one
issue about this definition is that the
presence of other diseases excluded a
diagnosis of chronic fatigue syndrome
the problem with that is that you could
for example get cancer after you had
chronic fatigue syndrome and
theoretically you would no longer have
chronic fatigue syndrome but obviously
that's not the case now a lot of the
patients are not pleased with a named
chronic fatigue syndrome because it does
trivialize the illness and results in
people not realizing how serious it is
this is a sampling of images that were
used to illustrate our recent microbiome
article the article that I'm going to be
talking about that concerns the gut
microbiome in any CFS these images
appeared in online and print news media
showing people who simply look tired
these people probably do not have muscle
pain problems with
with their joints and other aspects that
have nothing to do with fatigue as a
result of this in 2013 the Department of
Health and Human Services in the u.s.
contracted with the Institute of
Medicine that's a national academy of
medicine to convene a committee of
experts to recommend new diagnostic
criteria for mecfs
this resulted in the production of this
book here that that is can be ordered
and downloaded at no cost from their
website and this book really describes a
lot of the literature the the committee
reviewed the literature to determine
what was really established and what was
not established one thing that the book
has as key facts is that the estimates
of US prevalence are range from anywhere
from eight hundred and thirty six
thousand to two and a half million the
true number is really not known they
haven't been adequate epidemiological
studies and this is compounded by the
fact that many people with any CFS have
not yet been diagnosed there are more
women than men with mecfs estimates
perhaps two to one maybe even three to
one ratio and the average age of onset
is around 33 but there's quite a range
people can get this disease before the
age of 10 and after the age of 70 the
Institute of Medicine recommended some
new clinical criteria for this disease
the idea was to have diagnostic criteria
that would allow any type of physician
whether they are pediatricians general
practitioners or specialists to be able
to identify and diagnose this disease
what's required again is a substantial
reduction in activity for more than six
months and this is a reduction in the
ability to engage in what the
individuals were able to do before
either
occupational educational social or
personal and its new or definite onset
it's not something that has occurred
lifelong and it's not alleviated by rest
the other two requirements are post
exertional malaise which I'll be
describing in a few minutes and
unrefreshing sleep a fourth requirement
is that the individuals must have either
cognitive impairment or orthostatic
intolerance in other words the problems
with remaining upright and and with
their blood pressure autonomic nervous
system control a new name was proposed
systemic exertion intolerance disease
for the disease previously known as Emmy
or CFS this name has not yet caught on
with the patient community and it is
also not used very much in the
literature yet so I'll be referring to
this disease as any CFS throughout my
talk that is currently the preferred
name by most of the patient
organizations because post exertional
malaise is a very important symptom in
this disease in fact it even resulted in
the new name being exertion intolerance
I want to describe that a bit further
this is an exacerbation of a patient's
mecfs symptoms following exertion that
would have been easily tolerated prior
to their illness
the exacerbation typically occurs within
24 hours but it can last a few days to
even months and what happens with most
patients is they often reach a steady
state of exertion that they can tolerate
before inducing this post exertional
malaise now for some people this is they
can work part-time but if they try to
say one-day work full-time a whole day
they're unable to rebound the next day
they're often ill from that extra
exertion for other patients the ones who
are so-called housebound patients if
they do as much of going out to the
grocery store to shop they will then be
sick potentially in bed for the next few
days
and the people who have severe cases of
this disease just simply getting up to
go brush their teeth can make them sick
for the rest of the day in bed unable to
function post exertional malaise is a
symptom that can be objectively measured
by two successive cardio pulmonary
exercise tests so-called C pets this
shows an example of a seat pad in which
the person is exercising on a bicycle
and it's possible to measure the maximum
heart rate oxygen consumption the
ventilatory threshold the maximum
workload and the respiratory exchange
ratio an AR ER of greater than 1.1
indicates that participants are
performing work at maximal levels the
RER indicates the ratio of carbon
dioxide exhaled and oxygen consumed so
what happens to mecfs patients after an
exercise challenge it's now been
reported in four different papers this
is reproducible that when any CFS
patients perform a second C pet and
after they've induced post exertional
malaise by their initial C pet their
secret values are usually not reproduced
despite and re are of one greater than
1.1 indicating maximal effort the
frequent findings in the second C pad
are either lower maximum oxygen
consumption lower anaerobic threshold or
failure to produce maximum heart rate
failure to increase the blood pressure
or multiple abnormalities some patients
have multiple problems with these with
the second CPAP in fact one of the
amount of my colleagues who has tested
people by two successive C pets has
commented that sometimes when the person
comes in who is severely ill on the
second day when they're going to do
their C pet when they first get on the
bike before they've done any exercise
they are already using their anaerobic
metabolism really indicating that these
patients have post exertional malaise
now in contrast to mecfs patients
patients with other diseases including
heart fail failure or lung diseases are
able to reproduce their CPAP results so
this is really a unique finding in this
disease it's very useful for diagnosis
of course having to have patients do two
successive C pets is not something one
wants to do routinely and that's why the
new diagnostic criteria by the IOM will
be very useful one thing that should be
noted is that mecfs patients are
frequently encouraged to start exercise
programs because exercise often is
beneficial for various diseases but in
this case such programs can induce post
exertional malaise and can often cause
long-term increases in symptoms and this
is not to say that no exercise is useful
it just must be very carefully monitored
and it needs to be done at a level
that's not going to induce post
exertional malaise the biological basis
for this phenomenon is unknown and I
believe personally that it's going to be
very important to understand what's
happening when people have this post
exertional malaise induced it might give
us really insight real insights into the
problem in this disease now a number of
symptoms implicate immune activation in
any CFS there are a number of
inflammatory symptoms like sore throat
muscle pain swollen lymph nodes joint
pain flu-like feeling newer worsen
sensitivity and altered susceptibility
to infection so I want to briefly
discuss immune relationships and union
system relationships in this disease
there have been quite a number of
reports that there are abnormalities in
leucocyte function in any CFS this just
shows a collection of some of the titles
of some of the papers of concerning
abnormal leukocyte function this has
been known for quite a long time in fact
one of these pain
I have here is a report from 1994 in
which the investigators documented
abnormal natural killer cell function in
the patients with mecfs so with regard
to these research reports concerning
altered immune function one reproducible
finding is that there is reduced
activity of natural killer cells this
has been reproduced in several different
laboratories another finding that seems
to be reproducible is an altered
function of the RNA cell pathway other
asked other findings that implicate some
alteration and immune function is that
in a subset of patients treated with
rituximab which is an e cell depleting
agent there was market improvement this
is in a subset of patients not all
patients in another subset of patients
they were also able to have market
improvement when they were treated with
antivirals acted against herpes viruses
there have been a number of reports also
of abnormal levels of plasma cytokines
altered abundance of lymphocyte subsets
and abnormal t-cell responses
unfortunately of the many reports
there's a lot of inconsistency and so we
really don't know what's what's
happening in this definitively but I do
think there's enough smoke that there's
probably some fire and if we knew how to
do the assays consistently we might be
able to get consistent data on these
last three factors unless you also
mention that there have been outbreaks
of mecfs and of course outbreaks
implicate an infectious agent
one of the first outbreaks was in 1934 a
well documented outbreak at the Los
Angeles County Hospital since then there
have been a number of outbreaks in
hospitals or in groups of people that
are confined in a small location for
example on military bases
they seize an orchestra and also in two
small towns to the most famous outbreaks
are in Incline Village Nevada in 84 and
in Linda Ville New York in 85 there
seems to have been an increase in the
frequency of outbreaks and clusters in
the 1980s
now one peculiar aspect is that synth in
the last 20 years we have not had an
outbreak in the US that's been reported
of this disease that involving hundreds
of people the outbreaks in Incline
Village in the Lyndonville for example
were hundreds of people several hundreds
of people became ill with this disease
at that time why we're not seeing those
outbreaks now is not understood whether
there's been some change in virulence of
a pathogen whether there's change in the
resistance of the population to some
pathogen or whether we're simply missing
some of those outbreaks is not really
known no I do think if there were an
outbreak in a small town of several
hundred people that would certainly be
noticed there are however plenty of
cases for added cases arising and
there's a lot of anecdotal evidence
indicating that the prevalence of this
disease has been increasing since the
1919 80s and is continuing to increase
but there is not yet good epidemiology
to document exactly this change in
prevalence the sf-36 questionnaire is
often used to characterize mecfs
patients and victims of other types of
disease is the patient's figure fill out
of survey indicating some things like
whether they can carry groceries climb
stairs how much work they can do how
much pain they have they also fill out
questions about their mental health and
their mental psychological functioning I
this is an interesting paper that
appeared in nineteen this is data from
an interesting paper that appeared in
1996 that has been graphed without the
standard deviations in order to make it
easier to view
number of other papers have documented
this same finding and that is that any
CFS patients have less quality of life
than individuals with such known
important diseases as multiple sclerosis
congestive heart failure if we look here
this this is the this is the curve for
the people with any CFS you can see
their scores on the sf-36
are lower than the scores of the healthy
individuals up here and these scores are
also lower than people with such
diseases is high blood pressure
congestive heart failure diabetes heart
attack the multiple sclerosis the one
place where the people with chronic
fatigue syndrome in this study had
better scores were in the mental health
and the emotional role scores here they
have higher scores than individual with
depression so while they have worse
physical scores they have relatively
good mental health and emotional role
scores relative to individuals with
depression I now like to turn to my talk
about the microbiome in any CFS with
that background this study has been
published in the journal microbiome it
was a collaboration between my lab and
the lab of Ruth Leigh in my department
the collaborators the lead author on the
paper is a postdoctoral associate in my
lab Ludovic Julito Julia Goodrich and
Tony Walters worked in Ruth leis lab
Susan Levine is the our collaborating
physician let me just remark that with
regard to the human microbiota it's now
thought that there's as many microbial
cells as human cells in or on our bodies
but most of these are in the large
intestine and they are known to provide
enhanced nutrition and
protection against pathogen but can also
have other effects on our body the human
biker microbiome is known to be
associated with disease for example it's
known to be associated with obesity with
diabetes and with Crohn's disease but
one issue with regard to these diseases
as well as with mecfs are these
differences the cause of the disease or
a consequence there are a number of
factors that are associated with
composition of the gut microbiota
there's diet there's a health status
there's genotype and there's also age
now many mecfs patients complain of
gastrointestinal symptoms
gastrointestinal symptoms are not
required for either this 1994 CDC
definition of mecfs or for the new IOM
definition nevertheless many patients
probably the majority of patients
complain they have some sort of
gastrointestinal problem so the question
arises whether this abnormal
gastrointestinal function is causing
inflammation and therefore perhaps some
of the other symptoms and also whether
the gut microbiome of mecfs patients
differs from the health and healthy
controls so our study population was
provided by dr. Susan Levine from
Manhattan New York she has a number of
mecfs patients and she recruited the
patients and the controls
she drew blood and sent the blood to us
and also gave stool sampling kits to the
patients and the controls so there were
39 controls and 49 patients of these
patients
25 of them reported a sudden onset of
the disease often a patient can tell you
exactly what day they became ill and and
often it's after a flu-like illness the
age of the
trolls and the patients the median was
close as well as the body mass index but
you can see in both cases there's quite
an age range of the patients and
controls that were subjects and in a
quite a range also in the body mass
index of both with regard to intestinal
discomfort eight of eight of the 39
controls and 32 of the 47 patients who
reported information indicated that they
had some sort of intestinal discomfort
whether this was frequent diarrhea
constipation other pain oh that that's a
fairly high and expected complaint of
intestinal discomfort among the patients
the sf-36 profiles of the mecfs patients
in our study were very similar to those
in prior studies of any CFS the black
bar here shows the our studies any CFS
scores and again the scores on physical
functioning where we're pretty high I
mean pretty similar not high pretty
similar to the others other scores what
was higher was the role emotional health
and and mental health that these scores
were quite good relative to controls but
the physical vitality in particular was
quite low in comparison to what you'd
expect for healthy individuals so there
are some inflammatory markers in plasma
that are possibly related to intestinal
function and we wanted to assay all of
these markers
there's Lippa polysaccharide LPS which
is a component of the outer membrane of
gram-negative bacteria there's LBP which
is a human protein that binds to LPS
there's a receptor of soluble cd14 it
detects the presence of LPS bound to LBP
and then there is
if a BP which is an intestinal fatty
acid binding protein which can sometimes
be a marker on intestinal damage so just
to remind you that gram-negative
bacteria have little polysaccharides on
their surface and it's thought that in a
case of a dysfunctional gut sometimes
bacteria can go through the the gut if
if these cells are are not functioning
properly and enter the bloodstream and
then result in an increased amount of
LPS in the bloodstream which then can
induce inflammation so we carried out
assays of LPS and FA BP the graph here
shows the amount on the y-axis and
whether it's controls or mecfs patients
each one of these dots here is an
individual measurement of an individual
subject you can see that the controls
had less LPS on average than the mecfs
patients however there were some
controls and patients who had
approximately the same amount of LPS so
it's not entirely discriminatory for
patients versus controls in the case of
a BP we didn't see any significant
difference between the mecfs patients
and the controls however we were able to
see that there's evidence for a direct
stimulation by LPS in vivo and that is
the levels of LBP in the any CFS
patients are considerably higher than
those of the controls indicating again
that there's LPS stimulation the
receptor that detects the LPS bound to
LBP is also considerably higher in the
mecfs patients so there's definitely
some indication of LPS stimulation this
data
implies ongoing damage to the gut
leading to increased microbial
translocation now there are some other
diseases which also have increased LPS
and and that these are fatty liver
disease HIV infection Crohn's disease
and ulcerative colitis
so with this information
it seemed worthwhile to go on and also
analyze the gut microbiome in these
patients and controls this is how we
analyze the gut microbiome and bacterial
microbiome fecal samples were collected
preserved in a preservative and shipped
by the subjects themselves and then
processed at Cornell the DNA was
isolated from these fecal samples and
then 16s ribosomal RNA gene PCR was
performed and then the individual
patients sequences were obtained on an
aluminum I seek and we obtained as many
as 140,000 sequences per sample I'd like
to briefly comment about how we
classified the microbiota we used
operational taxonomic units instead of
species because we cannot know exactly
where they're some of the sequences we
found represent a different species or
we're simply similar so we used a
cut-off of 97% which is typically used
to identify an operational taxonomic
unit so if two sequences were 97%
similar than they were considered to be
the same species we then look to see in
this case we've got this little example
here there's three different ot use in
these in these mass Eight in these three
individuals so the pink individual has
more of OT UA the blue has less and
the Green has none and that kind of data
is what we used to develop a matrix of
similarity of the individuals
microbiomes so in this case the blue and
the blue and the pink individuals had
more similarity than the pink and the
green individual here so when we graph
this on a principal component graph we
can see that these the blue and the
green microbiomes this is representing
the entire microbiome of the blue person
the green person are more similar than
the one the person whose diagram is pink
in this example now of course we didn't
use just three ot use actually to make
such a graph we had to use a thousands
of OT use for each subject now when that
was done we and we looked at the
bacterial diversity again how similar
are the entire microbiomes of the
patients and controls we were not able
to distinguish the CFS patients and the
controls by this analysis this is not
unexpected because this type of analysis
is not adequate to distinguish the
microbiomes of other people with other
gut microbiome related diseases so for
example here is a paper about pediatric
Crohn's disease in which they had a much
larger cohort and analyzed in the same
way and you can see here that the red
and green dots are very close together
there's really no separation able to be
done in these patients with pediatric
crohn's disease versus healthy patients
so this is not a fine enough analysis we
had to use a different type of analysis
to see if we could determine some
differences between the patients and
controls so one thing that we performed
was to examine that one experiment we
performed was to examine whether
bacterial diversity within the mecfs
patient cohort
and a healthy cohort differed on the
y-axis is phylogenetic diversity how
many species are owed --use do are we
finding in the patients versus controls
as the number of sequences seek obtained
per sample increases this is called a
rarefaction analysis we can see that the
patients and controls differ in their
amount of species detected if you look
very early and you don't have very many
sequences you wouldn't see this
difference between the patients and
controls it's necessary to obtain enough
sequences that one can then begin to see
that there is in fact a loss of species
richness in mecfs microbiomes I'd like
to mention that after this paper was
published a microbiologist at Liberty
University Allen Gillan contacted me and
asked have you compared the micro biomes
of the individuals who reported
gastrointestinal disturbances to
patients who did not report
gastrointestinal disturbance and we'd
actually not done that analysis
so Tony Walters a ruthless lab kindly
checked on this and he found indeed that
the people who reported gastrointestinal
discomfort had less diversity than the
patients who did not report the
gastrointestinal disturbances so this is
an additional piece of information
indicating this abnormality could be
important we also discovered that we had
24 families in general that were
differentially abundant between mecfs
patients and healthy individuals this
these differences are statistically
significant so on this diagram here in
this red box are all of the group's
taxonomic groups that are less abundant
in the patients than in the controls
some of these ones that are back ot use
and species and
families in general are actually ones
that are known to be beneficial for
example members of the room in a Cox a/c
were significantly higher in healthy
individuals than in mecfs patients and
as some members of the Roma cot room in
a caucus a/c are known to produce an
anti-inflammatory protein they're also
known to produce butyrate which is an
anti-inflammatory fatty acid lower
levels of these butyrate producing
bacteria and reiterated South are also
seen in Crohn's disease and ulcerative
colitis
we then investigated whether we could
use the data to make a test for disease
status whether we could identify
patients versus controls using a
combination of the levels of LPS LBP and
s soluble cd14 in the blood with the
microbiome composition in the in our
patient cohort 55% were diagnosed by the
MD as having any CFS and 45% were
healthy in the case of the mecfs we are
actually able to identify 53% of that
55% as a me/cfs
unfortunately however we also identified
12 percent of the normal individuals as
having any CFS according to this test
nevertheless we were able to identify
correctly 30 percent of the normal
individuals what this means is that we
were actually able to identify correctly
83% of the cohort as having either any
CFS or not merely from three blood
levels of these inflammatory proteins
and the microbiome composition so this
is very promising and certainly
indicates that there is a biological
disruption in the microbiome composition
in any CFS with some additional markers
that may be possible to use this kind of
data to distinguish patients and
trolls there are some limitations to
bacterial microbiome analyses however
the data is inadequate to reveal whether
or not a particular bacterial strain is
differentially present in patients
versus healthy individuals for example
some of the patients could have a bad
type of bacterium a variant a strain of
a bacterium that we are only able to
identify that it belongs to a certain
species but we don't know if that's a
bad strain an example is e coli we would
know whether a coli is present in
patients gut microbiome but if it is the
pathogenic type of e coli that has
caused outbreaks of E coli related
disease we would not see that from this
type of analysis other type of analyses
would be needed to identify whether
there is any of that bad e coli present
these bacterial microbiome studies also
don't reveal what eukaryotic pathogens
or beneficial species might be present
such as the yeast and parasites we are
continuing on to analyze our data using
18's sequencing to study what what types
of eukaryotic species may be present we
this data also doesn't indicate where
their viruses are differentially present
and that is another type of analysis
that we are currently carrying out in
conclusion I have shown you that there
is less bacterial diversity in patients
compared to healthy populations there's
the association of abundance of
particular bacterial groups with mecfs
or with healthy status 83% of the
samples can be correctly classified and
anti-inflammatory bacterial species are
reduced in mecfs patients I'd like to
end by just describing briefly a case
report that is now impressed that was
done in collaboration with Betsy Keller
and exercise physiologist
at Ithaca College she had two
identical twins come to her for exercise
testing 4c pets and we thought this was
an opportunity to examine the gut
microbiome of two individuals whose
genotype is quite similar these were two
male twins age 34 one of them would had
mecfs for three and a half years at the
time of testing while the other one was
well in the first seep at the ill twin
had lower maximum oxygen consumption
than the well twin this indicates that
as you might expect the ill twin was
less physically fit than the well twin
likely not having been able to do much
exercise in the last three and a half
years but what was interesting and
relevant to what I described earlier
about exertion intolerance the ill twin
did not reproduce his results in the
first test when he did at the second
time after inducing post exertional
malaise the ill twin reached anaerobic
threshold at 3:13 percent lower oxygen
consumption so this again is that
abnormality of post exertional malaise
that's required for the diagnosis of
mecfs and the new definition the ill
twin had reduced gut microbiome
diversity very similar to what we found
when we were examining the larger cohort
and on the graph on the right what
you're seeing in these bar graphs is
each color represents a different
bacterial group and you can also see
that despite having very similar
genotype as you would expect for
identical twins there's quite a
difference in their bat bacterial
microbiome composition also similar to
the larger study so there is some
additional information about the our
mecfs microbiome study available on a
webinar that I gave last week this is a
patient focused webinar in contrast to
this one which
is really researcher and medical
professional focused I also gave a
patient focused presentation at the end
invest in any conference in London in
June and it's possible to get a DVD of
an entire conference at the website
indicated below we will also be
presenting some additional information
about the gut microbiome at the upcoming
ia CFS and II conference this is the
major scientific conference held on this
disease and it will be in Fort
Lauderdale in October and the lead
author on the bacterial microbiome study
will give some new information about the
viral microbiome and graduate student
Alexandre Mandarin Oh will give a poster
about eukaryotes in the any CFS gut
microbiome and thank you for your
attention
Thank You Maureen for that informative
presentation now time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask miss
Hanson please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
then click the send button we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for all right let's get
started our first question is marine is
there a genetic basis as to why some
individuals would have acquired a less
diverse microbiome or is it's thought to
be simply the car genetic effects on the
microbiome that are known there have
been studies in fact there's a very
interesting twin study being done by my
colleague Ruth ley to look at the
genetic effects on the gut microbiome
however in the case of mecfs we don't
know much about what effect the genetics
might have on the this difference in the
gut microbiome certainly in the case of
the twins who have largely the same
genome they have differences in the gut
microbiome despite having been raised in
the same household been exposed to the
same microbes initially my suspicion is
that the reason that's different is the
result of the ill twins alteration
resulting from his his mecfs status but
it would be very interesting to examine
the genotypes further next question
romina seats microbe I believe is
abundant in ruminants it is a vegetarian
diet better for mecfs management
know much about weather weather diet
okay we don't know how their diet is
actually helpful in mecfs patients
anecdotally report that certain diets
are helpful to them but there really
haven't been adequate studies to
conclude whether a vegetarian or
non-vegetarian diet is best for mecfs
patients next question has there been a
name Segal transplant studies and mecfs
patients there have there have been a
few anecdotal reports are very small
studies in which individuals have had
fecal transplants and there's at least
one report in a very small group in
which the patients reported improvement
after people transplants but there
haven't been large enough studies to
conclude whether or not this would be
helpful with the symptoms after
publishing our microbiome study I did
have several individuals privately email
me and say that they had had people
transplants and that it helped their
symptoms one individual in fact
indicated that he'd had one and it
helped for several years but then he had
relapsed and there was no you know he
relapsed back to his earlier state so we
really don't know if that if fecal
transplants would help it is something
that would be worth investigating next
question what are the exact or the
static intolerance from sums of immune
CSF
the aesthetic and tolerant symptoms are
usually seen as a problem when
individuals are upright they individuals
seem to be unable to control their
autonomic nervous system properly and
this is actually one of the more
disabling symptoms of the disease it
required results in some individuals
having to be prone or at least reclining
for most of the day because they're
unable to be upright this has been also
objectively demonstrated using a tilt
table test that many mecfs patients can
have an objective measurement of pots
postural orthostatic tachycardia
syndrome and other abnormalities upon
tilt table testing so this this is a
very common symptom and that's one
reason that it's required either
orthostatic intolerance or cognitive
difficulties we're having some great
questions coming in next question do you
think the actuarial microbiome analysis
result is the result or the cause of
mecfs
okay I can only speculate since I have
no evidence either way but if I were to
speculate it would be my opinion that
it's likely a consequence rather than a
cause of the disease however I do think
it is very likely a cause of some of the
symptoms I believe it could be
exacerbating some of the inflammatory
symptoms that people experience the
flu-like feeling some of the other
symptoms that the patients report so
even though I doubt that it's the cause
and I think it is a consequence that
doesn't mean that it wouldn't benefit
the patients to have some help with a
symptom improvement in the gut
microbiome could potentially improve
some of the other symptoms so because we
don't have a treatment for the disease
that is applicable to all patients just
like the people with headache sometimes
headache medication makes them more
comfortable I think if we could improve
the gut microbiome that could also
result in a benefit to the patients now
Maureen this question refers to the
twins that you spoke about in your
presentation did they and do they
currently live apart and if so would
they have developed a different gut
microbiomes as a result
these twins are currently living apart
and potentially some of the differences
in their gut microbiomes could be due to
the fact that they are living apart and
but the fact is that that a lot of your
gut microbiome is actually inherited
from your mother there have been a
number of studies showing that so it's
impossible to know since we don't have
their gut microbiome
available from before the the one of
them became ill we can't know for sure
so some of the difference could be due
to their living apart and having
slightly different diets on the other
hand the fact that the differences were
very consistent with the differences we
saw between the mecfs patients and the
controls makes me suspect that it's
likely that a lot of the differences are
due to the health status of the ill twin
next question
could the modulation of microbiome be a
solution for the illness do you have any
experience in that
okay
with regard with regard to improvement
in any CFS microbiomes
we don't really know how to do that
there have been some reports again often
small reports of improvement when people
took various interventions probiotics
and there have been anecdotal reports
that they're helpful but this is again
something that needs to be studied we
really don't know exactly how to improve
the microbiome of these individuals
whether one might improve it with diet
probiotics people transplants any of
those things are worth studying to find
out if we could improve the gut
microbiome of the patients
Cameron that's a two-part question first
question were the healthy individuals
who reported to have abdominal pain
included as controls in the study and
was there a difference in the diet
microbiome
between these individuals and the other
healthy individuals that's an
interesting question
just like the the fact that we needed to
go back and analyze the the patients who
had worse intestinal symptoms than the
others
we actually haven't gone back to analyze
whether the small number of healthy
individuals who reported there that they
had some intestinal discomfort we
actually haven't done that and it is
something that would be interesting to
do to see if they have worse you know
unusual microbiomes than the other
healthy individuals that would be
interesting to do but we actually have
not done that analysis we did include we
didn't discriminate against the
individuals who were otherwise healthy
but reported that they had some sort of
abdominal discomfort not necessarily not
necessarily pain some of these
individuals may have reported that they
had diarrhea or constipation frequently
so we didn't we given that we had a
fairly small cohort we we didn't
eliminate those individuals from the
analysis
okay we have time for one more question
let's see
Ryan were the CFS patients taking
medications and/or supplements which
might account for the differences in
their microbiome compared to controls we
did survey the patients and controls
before incorporating them into our study
the patients and controls were excluded
if they had taken antibiotics within
three months of the collection of the
fecal samples it was really not feasible
to exclude individuals who might have
been taking some supplements we did we
did you know questioned them about their
supplements but one issue about
controlling for supplements is that for
example we don't know if some of them
you know ate more yogurt than others or
so it's very hard to to restrict you
know to restrict on the basis of diet or
supplements but anything extreme like
heavy doses of probiotics or antibiotics
we would not want it we wouldn't include
them in the study
I would like to once again thank Lori
and Hanson for her presentation
Marie if you have any final comments for
us I hope my talk was informative and I
appreciate the opportunity to be able to
explain our work and also let people
know about the seriousness of the
disease known as mecfs thank you once
again marina before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing until
December 8 2016 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement on
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye